for the first time scientists say there
may be signs of life on
venus it exists in tiny molecules in the
atmosphere researchers don't know how it
got there
or what it means but it's drawing new
attention to earth's
nearest planetary neighbor as holly
williams reports it's a world
that couldn't be more different its
surface is hot enough to melt lead
and it's cloaked in clouds of toxic gas
but scientists now believe
something could be alive on venus or
actually
just above it professor sarah seeger
along with a team of international
scientists
spotted a molecule called phosphine in
the planet's atmosphere
using giant telescopes finding phosphine
it really leaves us with two
equally crazy ideas one is that there is
some
unknown chemistry and the other one is
that there's some possibility there
might be
some kind of life producing phosphate on
venus on earth
phosphine is produced by bacteria and
sometimes smells like
rotting fish an unromantic discovery on
the planet named after the roman goddess
of love
venus was the subject of much early
space exploration
but the sulfuric acid in its atmosphere
literally eats through spacecraft
and focus switch to earth's other
neighbor i like to think of venus
sometimes like as the neglected sibling
why neglected because so much attention
is on mars
that could now change with a tantalizing
discovery
that might be a sign of life for cbs
this morning i'm
holly williams do you feel like you've
neglected venus
yes yes i'll be penis today you remember
that book men are from mars
who knew they were competing news that
mars and venus were competing but
something was going on
if something's going on although i don't
think i'll be moving there anymore no no
no no
no no no if it eats the atmosphere eats
through spacecraft
it smells like dead fish yes